peu l'automne voici regret le salon de
l'automobile qui fête aujourd'hui son
50e anniversaire
inauguré par le président de la
république qui marque ainsi l'intérêt
qui s'attache à cette industrie
il proclame en ces temps de restriction
le trio peu de la voiture économique
la deux chevaux citroën traction avant
est dans cet esprit l'un des clous de
cette manifestation
après en avoir été le mystère avec ses 4
places ces cas à saint litres aux cent
c'est 60 heures
[Musique]
c'est après de sa célèbre simca les
transports mais présente aussi son
nouveau-né la simca 6
[Musique]
à côté de renault grégoire van hamme
présente des modèles basés sur
l'économie mais à côté de ces créations
imposé par l'époque une place éminente
reste fait à la belle carrosserie
française dont le fini le bon bout en
rallier dans le monde tous les supports
un demi siècle d'efforts et de réussite
c'est le salon de l'auto 1948
[Musique]